my name is Francesco I'm a game
developer advocate really am I'm a game
developer I've been making games since
1999 give or take
I'm a graphics engineer so I'm super
excited to talk about Vulcan it's a
graphics API is income I'm a geek and
it's gonna show I I worked on several
engines in my gaming career who has ever
played fable 2 here she did yep that's
my work
it's my engine with others and I also
work on CryEngine from Crytek the does
it run on crisis thinking I'm a geek
about graphics api's and today I'm super
excited to share this stage with two
titans of the mechanical system here in
me Tom and John who they will show you
what is tools and best practices to
bring to life console quality
experiences on mobile which is
unprecedented
we're going to talk about the volcanic
assistant which is a big ecosystem and
Tom will go in great details about it
and then we're going to talk about tools
because I mean really an ecosystem is as
good as the tools that you can run on if
you remember back in the day the Xbox
360 and the ps3 times the ps3 had
arguably better hardware but the games
on 360 were probably looking better for
a long time because of the amazing tools
that were running on the platform
I am super biased cuz I worked on a 360
but someone working on ps3 would tell
you that their tools were amazing to you
that's why they could make fantastic
games so we're gonna explore tools on
running on Vulcan and now what we use a
tool for all used tools for improving
game performance and jeongu will show
you how you can use these tools and you
can use best practices to literally make
games sing using Vulcan and then we are
not gonna have Q&A I don't know why it's
there but you know you can come
afterwards come talk to me here think I
am here standing on the shoulders of
these Titans to tell you that Vulcan is
viable on Android it's been a bumpy road
there are issues we know that I
personally work on games that either
ship Vulcan only or shipped with Vulcan
render that are making games and they're
making money
Vulcan is viable and we're gonna go to
great lengths to show you how and why
one of the characteristics of Vulcan is
well the driver overhead is much lower
compared to OpenGL which basically means
the things like state validation let up
in OpenGL happens all the time like
you're submitting a draw call and the
drivers like other states correct yeah
they are submitting and Rocco are they
really correct yes they are you check
right a second ago in Vulcan it's
something that you do once you cash you
build your state pipeline and off it
goes you render as many turtles as you
like with that pipeline and it's
immutable it doesn't need to be verified
every time this means lower driver had
lower CPU consumption lower CPU usage a
lower power consumption simple
assumption I mean you can use to build
as much as like which is for me one of
the main reason to start thinking about
Vulcan your CPU will be engaged
reasonably less than with a standard
OpenGL renderer which means that you're
gonna give more chances to the various
course to go to sleep and consume less
power
which also means that they're gonna have
less chances go into thermal throttling
I talked yesterday about it - for about
20 minutes
lower power consumptions means longer
battery life which means more money in
your pockets also Vulcan has been
designed from the ground up from the
beginning to be a multi-threaded API
which means that you can build your
common buffers in parallel on several
threads you're not stuck anymore into
this world where all your comments are
serialized into one thread and then off
we go to the GPU now you can take full
advantage of the multi-core architecture
that we run our phones on
again multi-threaded API means shorter
render frame times also means more
chances for the various scores to go to
sleep less battery consumption again and
here is what I like the most about
Vulcan the fact that I'm a graphics
engineer I write this engine I know when
the shadow buffer happens I know when
the values around the targets I'm
rendering to need to be rendered to I
know which texture I'm using I know
everything about my engine at least I
hope so I can tell the driver what
resources depends on what resources I
don't need a driver to try to figure it
out every frame from water submitting
I'm in full control with Vulcan and weed
control comes great responsibility there
is a higher chance to get wrong and Tom
will show you how to detect these cases
and do something about it
this is
the latest cry engine demo that was
featuring ray tracing
it's a Vulcan demo it looks stunning and
it runs on mobile without the retracing
part but this thing runs on mobile it
was running on my pixel 3 this video is
coming from my pixel 3 it's a direct
capture they ported this in two or three
weeks can you play it thanks
I strongly encourage you to come over
there and see it running on device this
is this is a nerd of special thanks to
more a temple addameer who put up this
demo in in no time I was amazed seeing
it running and now it's time for Tom
thank you thanks Fran so first to
correct all the things he said that are
wrong we're not gonna go into deep
detail about debugging tools or the
ecosystem because we only have 20
minutes and it's it's a big thing and so
what we're gonna do is take a very
high-level view of just a little bit of
it and then I'll go into great detail on
a few things that I think are exciting
I'm kind of assuming that Vulcan is not
new to most of you you kind of know the
basic principles and at least some of
you are probably more skilled than I am
because by the way I should say he's a
game developer I'm not never have been
sorry about that so as to who I am my
name is Tom I work for Arman the Mali
GPU team and I also chair the Vulcan
working group so I have two hats with me
today I'm going to talk from both
perspectives I will try to be clear
about when I'm talking about what so
10,000 foot view I tried to draw a
picture and the conclusion was it is
complicated I don't mean that in the
creepy social media sense I mean that
there are a lot of moving parts I work
mostly in the red stuff over there with
the specifications conformance
validation but there's a whole army of
people working including your family
friendly neighborhood dev Tech's what at
least one of whom you'll recognize on
the right
so the point of this slide is not to say
that it's complicated is to say that
there's a lot of people a lot of
software teams working very hard across
the ecosystem to make Vulcan a good
platform the whole ecosystem is much
bigger than it looks from the outside
what this slide doesn't show is the
growth that's been happening I tried to
draw a picture of that it was a total
non-starter what I'll show instead is
just a few quick slices through the data
to give you some sense so one thing I
track is SDK downloads I don't actually
have the data for Android I'm sorry to
say because their SDKs bundled but for
the Vulcan SDK for desktop this is what
we're seeing it's noisy but the growth
is continuous I also like to track
what's happening in open source Monday
night I went to github and typed Vulcan
at the very top level search box told me
there were 3126 projects that mentioned
Vulcan I've been doing that for three
years and I can plot the data and it's
as clean as a whistle
it's either linear or the second
derivative might be slightly positive
but the rate of growth there is very
impressive as well one of the things
that my committee worries about most is
making sure that you have quality
drivers to develop on so when we write
specs we also write conformance tests in
as much detail as we can afford to to
make sure that implementations that say
they implement the spec actually do so
we launched two three years ago with a
hundred thousand test cases in
conformance we're at four hundred
thousand today and you can do the math
again it's pretty linear so we expect
this to continue indefinitely we know
it's working because every time we add
tests the GPU vendors come back and say
oops
and then they have go often they have
work to do so that's a good thing in my
point from my point of view
finally of course there is content it
was kind of a slow rampion mobile
reflecting the fact that it took bulk in
a while to build up a substantial
footprint in the market last year was
the year when Falcon really became a
thing on desktop this year it's really a
thing on Android so a lot of very high
quality stuff shipping that's my that's
all the detail you get on the ecosystem
as a whole sorry
that's all I have time for what I would
like to do is zoom in from 10,000 feet
to 10 inches talk about a very narrow
advance in the tools ecosystem that I'm
really excited about and looking forward
to seeing seeing people use it's called
GPU assisted validation work was done by
lunar G with funding from valve and in
consultation with the working group
they're both members and we all go way
back I should say all of this part of
the talk is with my Vulcan hat on
talking for the working group not
forearm so hopefully you know how
validation works when your application
calls a Vulcan entry point it's going
through an ICD table and and reaching a
Hardware specific GPU specific driver
underneath and that ICD is doing no
error checking at all if it can help it
it assumes you're using the API
correctly if you're not something will
happen but it's not the drivers problem
so that's me that's one of the reasons
as Fran said that you're the drivers are
very efficient very fast but it's a
hellish debugging environment so to make
debugging and development possible we
provide validation layers so you can
tell the loader when it initializes the
ICD interface to insert validation
underneath then when you call into those
entry points the validation layer checks
them tells you if you're doing something
wrong before you and before it passes
the data to the ICD this works great for
things like invalid enum it works for
things like I'm
in shader code which I hope you know how
scurvy works if it declares a spear V
capability that your hardware doesn't
support it can catch that kind of error
those are all static errors
unfortunately most of the interesting
errors are dynamic so for example you
might have a GLSL shaders that starts
out declaring an array of six texture
samplers and if in your code you
reference one of those and you reference
outside the array that's a static error
speer V validation will catch it but
actually the compiler of GL s GL slang
will catch it first so you will fix it
and you'll be fine but if your codes
doing something dynamic if the index is
coming from a shader stage input or a
buffer or a texture the compiler can't
do anything and your host so what's
going to happen if you actually execute
this code and that index is out of range
the spec says you get undefined behavior
if you're lucky what that means is it
draws your geometry and there's a
texture corrupt or missing and you can
look at the picture and figure it out
but honestly you're usually not that
lucky usually either get device lost or
you just get something totally weird and
you just have no clue what's going on
and it takes your days and days and days
to figure it out so now we have
something better this is as of GDC again
we've made progress even since then the
way this works your application wants to
make a shader it loads in a sphere be
blob that's the binary intermediate
shading language it passes it to create
shader module if you have this
validation enabled the shim that is the
validation layer implementation grabs
the blob runs it through sphere V opt
which is a general-purpose
shader transformation engine and that
sphere V opt in this mode goes through
finds all the references to texture
descriptor arrays and sticks in extra
spare b code around them to check is it
in range or not if it's not right an
error log message and also coerce it to
be legal so that hopefully you won't get
device lost at least not right away so
that gets passed back goes down into the
native driver and the whole Schmeer gets
compiled when you eventually run a
command buffer that does this that
contains this code after the cut buffer
completes validation checks the log and
sees if there's something there if there
is it writes you a human readable
message so it's a lot of text but
there's a lot of information here so it
tells you for example what's the name of
the error they're supposed to have error
ID codes sorry we didn't get around to
that yet it tells you the details you
indexed out of range exactly like this
it gives you the handle of the command
buffer which is okay but mapping it to
your code is kind of awkward so
fortunately there's a debug extension
called ext debug utils you can use that
to give symbolic names to your objects
and if you've done that the logged
message will include a name the symbolic
name of the object as well as the handle
tells you which draw call in this case
the first one it gives you pointers to
other objects involved the pipeline
state object and the fragment shader
tells you the invocation as best it can
so in the case of a fragment shader it
gives you the frag cord where this error
occurred often you can look at the scene
and see what was being drawn or infer
things about it from that gives you the
index of the experience struction in
order to actually use that you have to
run the spirity disassembler on your
blob and read through it jump to line 1
1 6 and see what was happening there
it's not the easiest thing in the world
to figure out fortunately as part of
this project we also added debug support
that is - G support - GL slang the
shader compiler so
if you're in this situation and you
debug - GS this log message will include
the file name where your error occurred
the line number and it'll print out the
source line which is way cool it's
almost like debugging a real computer a
few things to note there are version
dependencies there is a performance cost
it is going to perturb the time course
behavior of your application the two
most important things it needs a free
descriptor binding slot if you're
working on an implementation that only
has a few and you're using them all it's
not going to work we have a fix for that
in flight it's not here yet the other
thing is that currently it only checks
image and texture descriptor arrays but
that's just us driving the Golden Spike
obviously this is extensible to all
kinds of things and in fact we've
already landed partial support for the
ext descriptor indexing extension aka
bind 'less so if you were waiting for
that
you know bind list is kind of noisy to
debug we have a fix for you coming so
more information available thanks again
to lunar G so switching to my other head
you all saw the Hat so I can take it off
right so like most GPU vendors we have a
developer support team based in
Cambridge UK but with outposts around
the world and their mission is to make
is to help you use Vulcan well use it
efficiently particularly on Mali but
most of what helps on Mali helps
everywhere
so making Vulcan great is as part of
their mission and they do that typically
first by one-to-one interactions with
you if you file a sport issue at Mali
developer comm they're the guys who
answer you and work with you that
doesn't scale well so they also do blog
posts they do sample code tutorials etc
that scales but it is hard to build
intuition you have to read it over and
over and talk to people it's kind of
annoying so in hopes of making that
situation better what we released at GDC
this year is a toolkit we call the
Vulcan best practices toolkit this
bundles together tutorials
sorry it's sample code that shows you
things we think you should do also shows
you things we think you should not do so
we have that together with text
tutorials that walk through it and
explain the whys and wherefores but then
the thing that's new and and I think
novel is it there's also a plug-in
framework that all of these samples plug
into so that you can experiment with
them toggle the recommended and non
recommended practices on and off and see
how that affects performance so if you
look at it in this case this is a sample
that looks at load/store ops at the
beginning and end of you know what you
do with a frame buffer at the beginning
and end of a render pass and it lets you
just toggle between different options
for the for the depth attachment and the
color attachment but important to note
the scene in the background is totally
boring Wow can we can we play that again
the scene in the background is boring
but that's configurable all the source
code is there you can load different
scenes you can add your own there's a
gltf importer you can put your own
objects in it so you can try all sorts
of things you can change the shaders and
and see all sorts of things happen and
experiment with it Thanks
the other thing to notice that it's
multi-platform it is not Molly specific
some of the performance counters that
print out at the top are Molly specific
but you can run this code on a Adreno
device and you'll see what happens in
the case of demos that have
frame rate as their principal metric you
can see differences between how Molly
reacts to something and how Audrina
reacts to it and that's by design we
want you to have that information other
things to say about this also included
in the project are guides to using our
more advanced development tools which
I'll talk about in a minute as I said
it's all on github it's all free and
we're working on trying to share this
codebase with other GPU vendors in the
Android space so that we have give you a
better basis for exploring the
performance quirks of different GPUs and
tune your code in other words don't
always take our advice it might be bad
on another GPU you need to make that
trade-off and we want you to have the
information to let you do that so the
last thing I'll talk about is what I
call the power tools these are the tools
that our support team uses if you call
in with a problem they can't figure out
and you send them code and they have to
sit down or sit down next to you and
explore it there's two graphics analyzer
is one this used to be called Mali
graphics debugger and it used to be Mali
specific it no longer is to be quite
honest it's very similar to render doc
if you're using render doc today and you
like it
you may not need this the only thing it
has that render doc doesn't is it's more
aware of the performance counters that
Mali exposes we're hoping to add that
capability to render doc so it's a good
tool we use it all the time but it's not
something that you necessarily should go
and download unless you're working with
Mali a lot and having trouble the tool I
do recommend that everybody check out is
stream line this is our the arm total
army ecosystem performance analyzer
which gives you sort of systrace like
traces of what's happening on all the
CPU cores processes etc it also does
that for all the GPU cores if it's Mali
and it also allows your code to inject
events and put little flags into the
code so you know exactly where to look
it's really quite awesome there were two
things about these two tools that used
to really bother game developers and
that kept a lot of people from using
them and they kept telling us we can't
use it those things were it cost money
and you had to root the phone you are
running on in order to have access to
the performance counters so I'm very
pleased to say as of GDC ish there's now
a starter edition which is free so you
can try it kick the tires see how you
like it and the other thing with some
caveats you no longer have to root the
device that is assuming that the device
is written according to our guidelines
were working with our partners to get
them to do that some are some are quick
to do it some are slower if you have
companies like Samsung that are very
dedicated to providing a good developer
experience they are very quick to adopt
so s9 is supported as ten will be
supported in about two months there are
some things we have to fix on our side
that are keeping it from working we have
a list online you can go and see what's
there so there's links which I hope you
can find online and with that I'll turn
it over to John whoo my my good buddy
from Samsung
[Applause]
thank you Tom
hi I'm joking reading GPU and game there
is Samsung mobile I will share a bokken
optimization practices from our partner
collaboration before jump into there I
hope to give you some introduction first
the game is so important for Samsung
because that what we really care is not
just device that also user experience
comes from the device the high fidelity
game is one of the most serious and
hearted shipping is expensive mobile
because in mobile everything is limited
by form factor
the fundamental performing difference
between PC and Mobile is come from
different of the thermal design power
budget and battery capacity within this
phone factor a limitation and even we
keep chasing peak performance ticket is
not something you can keep using for a
sustainable worker like gaming because
of this optimization is so important in
mobile than any other area not for the
trade of optimization between quality
and performance but for the real
optimization for great performance
within even higher fidelity the new
technology to breakthrough the
fundamental problem are essential like
pork and 64-bit multi thread rendering
are those we really Balkan is the most
demand a new technology to achieve this
so will happily focus on balkan for
recent four years to accelerate adoption
of pork and we realized making many best
practices with the real market games are
required but game developer are always
busy so we announced the Galatea gained
about 2016
Samsung Hugh came develop a support
program a hopping Android game
helping under it game ecosystem with
adoption of new technologies these our
key partners and you can see both big
players and also the indie developers
you you can see both the unity
and you import developers at the same
time the multiple in-house game engine
developers 2:30
there they were taking the risk of the
bring new technology into their game
development and always aiming a higher
goal and quality and performance I want
to say thank you to all partners to give
us a great chance to work with them the
game that team has around the 30 game
dev engineers from five different
location
they worked hard sometimes on site the
partner developer studio sometimes also
remote support at their offices and also
how to say thank you the team for your
all contribution to show bright future
of laundry gaming ecosystem the during
live collaboration where the game
developers we learned a lot there are
key four key areas of game optimism you
think about tool and SDK pool and GPU
bender like arm are now worked hard as
francisco and tom more dimension
so now i focused more on the other areas
GPU driver the game engine and developer
support all these three are not perfect
at this moment in android
that's true the first GPU driver the
quality and performance both are two
main requirement from android game
developers we are poor working tightly
with the GP panda like arm for
optimizing GPU driver this is the graph
of the GP frame time of a heavy GPU seen
in fortnight it took around a 29
millisecond in march but now it reduced
to the 22 millisecond in november with
the same Mali GPU average frame gain is
around 5% just with the drivers of their
communication improving quality of the
GP driver take it a longer time so for
updating the progress of this we are
working with the Google teen as
availability of GP driver in android
this will bring better way of updating
GPU driver by play installation
and how to ship this feature as soon as
possible to help both game developers
and also end users even with better
quality and performance of GPU driver
game engine is also one of the big area
to make both can support well for the
real game development unity has
something agreed to support our liberal
community developers at 2017 and now
multiple unity games support book and
and show real performance benefit Final
Fantasy 15 Pocket Edition is one of
those we had a forum on site camp at
Okinawa where the screenings and
summertime studio with the many pork and
optimization on unity between renderer
and finally we get the 42 to the 60
frames per second performance game
one of the main optimization we made was
about Piper and berries
let's talk more about the PI parent
barriers we picked up the heavy Berta's
job example to show impact overusing
wrong Piper and bear yourself this
spoken sample is showing the serialized
vertex and fragment job during GPU
processing with es5 stream line capture
so performance is not that kill 262
millisecond GB from time a pipeline
barrier create an execution dependency
between the two after pipelines excuse
me of the current round path will wait
at the destination stage until the
execution of the former random pass has
that completed in so stage in
considering the narrow down to the two
and the passes an example shadow and
name with the knife case main always
await until completion of all that
pipeline stages in is shared around the
pass all about text fragment job are
enough fully paralyzed and those two
ground offensives take a twenty eight
milliseconds if we consider pipeline
barriers set more optimal in this case
we can set beginning of the fragment
stage for the main render path
need to wait until the completion of the
shadow Rande pass after changing
pipeline barriers said you can see
shadow and mainland affairs are in the
bleep idolized and those two rounded
pieces take last time now the 22
milliseconds we can optimize all granted
pieces of this simple with same manner
and see overall frame time reduced from
the 62 millisecond to the 40
milliseconds same walk Road but take
less time we also supported the tension
timmy studio l1 or ARB Kings who can
help a lot to improve performance of
honoured King and even with the s7 it
show the big performance game like 41 to
the 53 3-pack frame per second another
optimization we made is off roading
unnecessary roll store operation each
attachment of render pass has a set
operation for a road and store this
should be carefully managed to avoid
unnecessary overhead to world and store
the attachment between the ownership
memory and host memory
hundred saw by pound 13 also gets the
noticeable performance gained by poking
and the render PES road art store
optimization also had a lot in this case
too we you all know something in epic
games had a good relationship we worked
together developing protester demo and
may the same agreement to support all
ebook and ue4 developers too so we did
many contribution to you for balkan one
of the recent ue4 obey the collaboration
was the tangent game for pop t-mobile
and we did many works but update this
cassette let's talk about the difficulty
said about fiscal to set up more
in jail here the process of setting
uniform data is simple and writable but
how about walking canes
first we define the how many difficult
said descriptive type is needed on the
pipeline stage and allocated descriptor
sad with that information after this
shield prepared information of a uniform
bar for an image in the white ticket the
SAP structure and here we need a locator
BK buffer for a uniform data now we can
update this script asset with the
calling BK up date picker to set and
find the descriptor set finally we can
use the data or image on the part line
is so complicated but let's forget about
it please just remember we need to
allocate buffer and call became rich
data set in ideal case which has a
static object and beaudreau action we
can allocate a VK Bob for once and
update it to the set initially and just
reuse them everlasting but in relocated
things are more dynamic we we cannot
predict which object and are generated
or destroyed and so whenever the object
are created or destroyed we need to
allocate or relieve the buff for every
time and this will cause a huge overhead
in CPU solution is allocating a huge
buffer and using offset on the buffer
information structure in in this case we
can deploy the frequent allocation of
the BK buffer
but because the buffer information
structure is the part of the BK write a
script asset so we still need to call BK
update descriptor set every time before
binding descriptor sell better solution
for avoiding overhead over calling
updated every time is using dynamic
offset when binding descriptor set
in this case dynamic upset when finding
this kid said no sorry in this case we
can set the offset value on buffer
information as zero and we just deliver
the object information with a dining
table set array in the PK command pine
descriptor cell with summary this
optimization is a multi CPU side off
roading
we could manage PK buffer by using upset
we also killed manage be captive
descriptor set cause by using dynamic
opposite with the spoken sample using
offset cases shows about the 99% with
and still CP wounded using dynamic
opposite case show the 24 frames per
second and now last CPU bounded but more
GP working under these trees show the 25
millisecond taking a bigger update this
data set is gone after dynamic opposite
optimization off roading cpu have the
GPU works better and more trial very
recent work with an axe in more games
and update this with the cell
optimization have a lot to and this gave
a 35 to the 56 frame per second gained
by overall vulcan optimization within
the galaxy game dev support the game
developers who want to develop high
fidelity android games
we support the optimized party games and
GPU driver or better broken supporting
Galaxy devices but from this all we
found goes to the GPU vendor and the
game engine companies for a wider
description we we are also contributing
to the Android with dual
and Buchan working group within Cronus
our Father goal is improving overall
Android gaming atlas system better thank
you
[Music]